[Music]
playing with five fouls is college
there's damien again getting a step and
laying in it steals the inbounds goes
right back then it scores he's fouled
and he hits to the line
see I wanna put this banner on a
commercial three-in-one Blazers at home
two and one
[Applause]
[Music]
beautiful fly
[Music]
and got hit in the head too we could
have been in n1 I'm coming into this
game there's seven and oh when they lead
at home going into the fourth quarter as
they did tonight Damian Lillard
rearranges in midair and laid it in and
draws the foul and he will go to the
line is getting to the rim it doesn't
matter how you jump how you challenged
you will find a way under over-the-top
around your arms to finish
he recovers they gave the buyer to three
what's up boppers so this is a vehicle
take it guys
who's right ass white drives into the
lane draws the pump out of it goes it
does little fact and scoop short that is
as deep as it gets
shove the Python places have two
timeouts
bullets shot out of a cannon right to
the rim pulls the Blazers to within two
he works the sixth ninth frame deep deep
tap to the Lance lose control by the
Blazers Damien the other way hanging on
I mean he comes on two BOTS twist hurts
pleaded in the main is fouled and
Leonard hits to the line
[Applause]
[Music]
on the house filing at tip crap minor
kids comes in a gente Lillard
Lillard into the paint turns swings it
to Aminu makes a tremendous catch back
to daybreak Damian Lillard from the
Outer Limits reels in the three Blazers
lead at 110 109 5 and 1 10 seconds left
in the overtime you to pound the page
Lillard a on the way breaks it up to a
bigger role as he avoids just it ended
up at one is that as nice as finish
we've seen that's it's gotta be
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what up at you boy Adam left code you
like that content I know you like that
content hit subscribe for more of it
from Bleacher Report